[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hey, everybody.
Welcome to the ML & AI
sandbox here at I/O 2019.
So in the keynote, we
saw some amazing stuff
that you can accomplish
with on-device ML.
And I'm here with
TensorFlow Lite,
showing developers how they
can build that same stuff
themselves.
So you've got everything
from object detection
to image classification
and voice recognition.
And we're showing people
how they can deploy that
down to devices
that are really tiny
and run for weeks
on a single battery.
So to really show you what's
possible with TensorFlow Lite
on-device, we built this amazing
experience called Dance Like.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
Behind me is Dance Like.
It's super fun application
using TensorFlow Lite, which
is TensorFlow's mobile and
embedded systems framework
for running machine learning.
It basically teaches
people how to dance.
And so it does this by running
pose segmentation on the GPU.
We have a bunch
of GPU-related ops
that we just released
for TensorFlow Lite,
so you should check those out.
It enables you to run
super fast models.
We're running two in real
time and giving the user
a heap of feedback, which
helps them dance better.
So to go and build really
interesting applications
on mobile phones,
embedded systems,
and executing this
all on-device,
you can go to
TensorFlow.org/Lite.
There's heaps of sample code.
There's lots of
documentation and tutorials.
And you can go and build an
amazing application like Dance
Like and release
it to the world.
SPEAKER 3: What we're looking at
here is a model called PoseNet.
PoseNet is a model
that's trained
on images of human
beings, and is trained
to predict their skeletal pose.
This model here is
actually running entirely
in the browser with a
library called TensorFlow.js.
TensorFlow.js is a machine
learning library for JavaScript
that can run entirely
in the browser
and use your GPU through WebGL.
Now, TensorFlow.js also runs
in Node.js using the entire
TensorFlow C++ binary and all
of its hardware acceleration
storage behind it.
Piano Genie is a model that
runs in TensorFlow.js, entirely
in the browser as well,
that generates MIDI notes
as part of a piano performance.
Now, this model is
interesting because it
brings a human in
the loop and lets
the human condition where the
model is actually going to go.
TensorFlow.js is open source
and is available online
on TensorFlow.org/js, as
are multiple more examples
and demos of how to use it.
Head over there today to start
building machine learning
for the browser.